So yeah, saying you believe in CD19 positive stem cells and multiple myeloma is kind of like saying you believe in aliens. But I think we're making some believers out of people. So the concept is that potentially there's this B cell like CD19 positive multiple myeloma cell that's acting as kind of a reservoir for a small amount for the bulk of myeloma to come back after patients relapse.
And there have been some studies that suggest this, other studies that refute this, but some looking at low-level microscopy in patients that are CD19 negative by flow that actually show a very small expression of CD19 on their multiple myeloma cells.
So maybe there's something there for dual targeting that could potentially mitigate antigen escape.
And the rationale for designing this BCMA-CD19 dual targeting CAR-T was partially.
But partially also to make a versatile CAR and then also would limit the development of anti-CAR antibodies in the future.
So this is a dual targeting CAR-T cell with a loop configuration of both binding sites.
It's lentiviral vector transduction, 401BB co-stimulatory domain, and the next, actually next day manufacturing of the CAR.
The majority of the time it takes is the quality checks that take to get to this vein-to-vein time of about...
12 to 14 days.
So the CAR-T is actually manufactured 22 to 36 hours over, basically overnight in ex vivo culture medium with IL-2 stimulation.
And then the, there's no ex vivo expansion step.
All of the expansion of the CAR-T takes place in vivo in patients.
And this actually has led to, regardless of which dose level was tested, the same peak expansion among patients in the phase one trials.
And the conservative.
The conservative estimate is a vein-to-vein time of 14 to 16 days.
I would say we've seen more about 11 to 12 days.
And so Karina went over some of this data from the relapse refractory.
So I'm going to just gloss over it.
The highlights are that, you know, high response rates to toxicity was very remarkable with no ICANNs, no delayed neurotoxicities, no IEC colitis.
I'm sorry, one grade one ICANNs.
The overall response rate was 96%.
And among those who had had prior BCMA CAR-T therapy, which was five patients in the phase one data that's been presented from DERGO1 so far, a 100% overall response rate with an 80% stringency ROCR rate and MRD negativity rate of 94%.
But wouldn't it make sense if you have a safe CAR-T cell product and you're thinking you're going to achieve that C word, cure, and you're thinking about targeting the myeloma stem cell, maybe using this in the future.
And so I would say that, you know, high response rates to toxicity was very remarkable with no ICANNs, no IEC colitis.
But wouldn't it make sense if you had a safe CAR-T cell product and you're thinking you're going to achieve that C word, cure, and you're thinking about targeting the myeloma stem cell, maybe using this in the future.
And this came also with, you know, in addition to a great safety profile, 100% overall response rate across both trials, with the majority achieving CR or better.
Additionally, this was by month one, 100% had achieved 100% MRD negativity by Euroflow at 10 to the minus sixth.
And this wasn't persistent in everybody, but the majority did have sustained MRD negativity across six and 12 months.
So 83% with sustained MRD negativity, 12 months after receiving the product.
This translated to very encouraging progression-free survival.
So with medium follow-up of 36 and a half months, about 90% remaining progression-free.
And the patients that did eventually progress, most of them did die from disease progression.
So 83% associated with better PFS and OS, and those that had sustained MRD negativity at 12 months, which once again was 83%,
did not have any progression and remain alive to this day.
In regard to the CAR-T-cell expansion, despite patients, regardless of which cell dose they got,
they saw peak expansions that are considered comparable to what we see with other cell products.
And now there's a phase 1B study of...
The same product in newly diagnosed myeloma, the DERGATUTE study,
basically replicating what was done on those previous IITs in China.
I'll be more than happy to present the updated data at the next Whistler conference.
Yeah, well, I think we will.
So we have fast car and faster speakers.